the city of Sakura in the province of
Cochabamba is in mourning Marco Varga
Martinez was shot during the protest
carried out by Evo Morales supporters
here his relatives say he was shot in
the head we are sad and hurt because he
is not the only one that was killed they
took the others a few hours away we want
a solution because when we took him to
the clinic we had to pay a lot we want
justice Evo Morales resigned last week
after being accused by the OAS of
committing fraud in the presidential
elections but for these people he was
the man who dignified them most of these
people are from indigenous communities
and our coca leaf growers and they were
trying to go through the main road
towards the capital La Paz but they were
prevented by the police they had to
escape and they're telling us that they
were ambushed right in this place this
Facebook live video was filmed by one of
the protesters say sir CP Merida was 18
years old and was shot in the stomach
while filming the clashes live he was
killed that day they are militarizing
this whole area because they want to
believe we are criminals they shot at us
from everywhere and they can do it
because we are poor the actions of
security forces are currently being
investigated they're accused of using
live ammunition and excessive force on
promotoras demonstrators the
inter-american Court of Human Rights
says at least nine people were killed
here and over 130 were injured
Cochabamba sone boatman says the
response by the military was
disproportionate what happened was a
massacre in this country they want to
say it was a confrontation on Friday the
government issued a decree that
exonerates the armed forces of any
killing and one hour after that decree
the police in the military started using
live ammunition against protesters the
government says the protesters were
infiltrated by foreigners and were using
improvised weapons ammo Perillo we have
asked the Attorney General to
investigate what happened he told me
that the
was because the relative did not want to
leave the bodies we have asked the
Attorney General to investigate this as
soon as possible the Cochabamba tropic
was the launching pad for evo morales
political career as a leader of the coca
leaf Growers Federation many people here
remain loyal to him and do not trust in
the new interim administration many say
a call for elections and political
negotiations are crucial to prevent
further loss of life three Tsavo
al-jazeera sakaba Bolivia